in the world of fake news we no longer
have to worry about hoaxes we now have
to deal with hoax hoaxes Friday when
President Trump called the Dems attempt
to politicize the coronavirus a hoax how
did the media portray that that he was
calling the virus a hoax
yeah the Washington Post Dana Millbank
kicked it off with this remember this
moment Trump in South Carolina just
called the coronavirus a hoax Politico
lazily picked it up with this headline
Biden blasts Trump for calling
coronavirus a hoax true the hoax hoax
spread like a virus too desperate
Democratic candidates Joe Biden and also
Mike Bloomberg trumpeting this lie even
though anyone who read Trump's actual
quote could see it was BS but the media
expects us not to do that they hope our
laziness will let hoaxing hacks like
Milbank get away with their
misinformation and if you point out
their lies then cnn's hall monitors will
accuse you of politicizing it the I know
you are but what am i school of debate
that is then met with laughter but even
as there are hacks there's hope as
better reporters now promptly call out
these fake news viruses after Bloomberg
blasted Trump for calling it a hoax
reporter Scott Pelley stopped him
I find it incomprehensible that the
president would do something as inane as
calling it a hoax which he did last
night in South Carolina he said that the
Democrats making so much of it is a
Democratic hoax not that the virus was
about this is up to the scientists and
the doctors as to whether there is a
problem there you go Pelle wasn't the
only one others on Twitter quickly
called out the lie which forces the
media to find another path to hammer
those they hate that's the problem with
the media's bias it's not so much
contagious as it is incurable
the best defense washing your hands of
them that was a landing of a line
washing your hands of them I should just
leave right now I should just go home
and get in a get to my house early and
have ribs alone in the dark Emily yes
what do you think
no Facebook actually identified the
political story as fake news that's
pretty cool Facebook
I think you know it's troubling that
we're hearing these guys parrot the same
things that have been debunked
especially when it's so easy and it's
it's it's in the face of something that
has the potential for a really big deal
on this country for them to be obsessing
over the president's response the market
had its worst week in 12 years so that
shows you what humans take seriously
it's not impeachment trials it's not oh
my gosh collusion it's not all of this
stuff that's been rammed down our
throats as opposed to the next
Armageddon it actually is a public
health situation so to me it kind of it
brings up and highlights what is
important and certainly the media's
coverage the obsession with the hoax
comment it's off the mark you know Dana
they also said Trump was muzzling foul
Qi and then that turned out to be a will
foul Qi pushed back on is one of my
three have the sound how dare you not
have sound Dana just like a daily
briefing
I do love doctor pouchy and I like it
that he stepped up to the podium to say
let me be very clear I wasn't muzzled
and when he was explaining made a lot of
sense when the president put
vice-president pence in charge the vice
president was like let's just take half
a moment to look at all the things that
we're doing all the different parts of
government and get one cohesive unit so
that we are speaking clearly and
transparently into the American people
that made a lot of sense to me
also when it comes to if you're on the
campaign trail and you hear something
that sounds just too good to be true
right and that President Trump said that
you want to run with check yourself
because it usually is not true and then
you look foolish mm-hmm Jesse should the
media apologize to you you really were
excited about that monologue where you
know the ending I thought about why you
excited washing your hands of them was
like a nice turn of phrase I'm quite
proud of I'd only get one of those a
year one a year no I think you'd do more
than that but Congrats Gregg well said I
think the president has handled this
virus very well only two things I think
you can criticize the guy for if you
look at the CDC they had the
contamination at the test site they got
the test kits out too slowly and a CDC
hospital work
released a woman who was infected she'd
been tested positive that was a mistake
those are sub sensitive issues that you
can say you guys better clean that up
and they have cleaned those things up
but to say that you know the president's
lying to say that he's muzzling doctors
to say that he's cutting the CDC is
ridiculous to say that the task force is
too white or Pence is too religious to
run it is ridiculous to say yeah Pence
is gonna pray the virus away he's not
equipped to handle this the New York
Times runs two columns comparing the
presidents of the virus
Paul Krugman celebrates the Dow dropping
the Washington Post encouraging
Democrats to make hey politically out of
the virus and my favorite CNN says that
the travel restriction that Trump did
was racist and would backfire and today
they CNN puts their own travel
restriction on their own employees
because it's such a big deal so look at
the Dow look at this study that said
that the United States is the best
prepared country to handle this and
Gallup poll says that 77% of the
American people are confident in the
administration's response to the virus
speaking of CNN wat there was a there
was a lower third they had when they
said like can we stop the coronavirus or
Bernie Sanders so it's like kind of like
why would they put that together yes but
I have something to say here because I
think exacerbating the kind of political
divide makes people less safe and to my
mind the virus is a political the virus
will get you to matter where you are
right so I think people see through that
to have people see the virus through a
partisan lens is to me dangerous I mean
it's a little bit like you know the
anti-vaxxers who made this thing so
political whether or not you've acts say
I think that's crazy and I think it's
regrettable so yes I agree with you that
the President did not say that the virus
was a hoax what he said was the
Democrats the way that they're talking
about it mounts to a hoax but guess what
Greg a lot of the people at that rally
interpreted as not you know what this
might be a hoax
and I think that meant for them for them
it was like you know what we've got
nothing
worried about the personís that's the
reaction in fact after I don't have fine
reading excuse me I don't know it's not
yes because you know what you watch in
terms of the conservative media
environment the websites the talk radio
it's all oh you know what you don't have
anything to worry about this is coming
from the Trump statement it's a hoax and
again you talk about people who
misinterpret what the hoax was they're
interpreting it as the hoaxes so it's
not a big riot at the rally that's what
no no no I'm talking about media voices
that you can put names to and I'm saying
this is dangerous because it should be
apolitical from both sides not just once
I say oh yeah where the a platino
America the virus will get you unless
you take the appropriate steps pay
attention don't get emotional and we
trust our leaders you know what I think
though the population is getting smarter
about report like taking reporting at
face value in a weird way their
skepticism is their immune system oh and
you did it again yes